if we're all god's children
what's so special about jesus
[Applause]
i don't know if there is a god that's
all i think you can say honestly i mean
you could say there is a god if you
believe in it that's
you can just get to say it because you
believe it you can't argue with
somebody's beliefs
i believe in god now you don't yes
i mean that's a it's faith it's not
science it's faith i i envy people who
have faith they wake up in the morning
and there he is they're like oh hi
that's so nice that you came again today
he's always there
i don't have that i wake up and there's
nobody it's just my bad breath and my
garlic penis it's it used to be at least
a boner that i
all right let's get going but it's just
so
but i don't think you can say there's no
god uh because that takes a lot of
boy that takes a lot of confidence to
say nope there's no
definitely not a god how do you know
just cause uh
doesn't seem like there's one so
there's not one
how can a human being think that they
know
that there isn't anything i mean you're
a human
you can see for a hundred yards tops
how could you possibly know god might be
right behind you all the time just like
i think if there is a god it's probably
not the one the way they describe him in
the bible they say he's our father
and we're his children that's a weird
story
he's our father and we're his children
where is our mother
how how can we how could we not what did
he do to our mom
something happened
somewhere in heaven there's a porch with
a dead lady under it
[Laughter]
i think i thank god it was uh if there
is a god at the mo
at least he has an ex-wife maybe that's
what it is god's divorced
and it's a cut where it hit like this is
our weekend with god
it feels like a long time but this is
just our weekend with dad
and then he's gonna take us to mom's
apartment
and she's gonna be sitting there kind of
nervous like maybe a cheese sandwich
and we're we're like i don't know you
[__]
and it feels weird i think that
uh i think that we made god a man
because we
wanted men to be in charge so it made
sense because it doesn't make sense that
men are in charge
it makes sense that women would be in
charge because your mom
is the first person who takes care of
you so how and you got it just makes
sense that
mothers would run the world and uh they
do
it's the opposite so we have this weird
system of
uh you know men being it's kind of
upside down and i think the reason is
because women were in charge long time
ago
and they were really mean they were
horrible
and you they would you had to walk
around naked and they'd flick your penis
and laugh at you
so we're so scared of them
and then finally one guy punched a woman
she was like he's like we can hit them
and then that was it
that was it but you know the longer you
listen to this abortion debate
the more you hear this phrase sanctity
of life you've heard that
sanctity of life you believe in it
personally i think it's a bunch of [__]
well i mean life is sacred who said so
god
hey if you read history you realize that
god is one of the leading causes of
death
has been for thousands of years hindus
muslims jews christians all taking turns
killing each other because god told them
it was a good idea
the sword of god the blood of the lamb
vengeance is mine
millions of dead [__] millions
of dead [__] all because they
gave the wrong answer to the god
question you believe in god no
dead you believe in god yes
you believe in my god no dead
my god has a bigger dick than your god
[Applause]
i believe in god man i don't believe in
religion
i think religion is [__] up
you understand me because i think crazy
white people wrote the bible
you understand me you know i think
people call it the word i believe god
wrote his word in your essence you
understand me that's the genius of my
father it's written in your essence
nobody ever had to tell you it's wrong
to kill your mama
somehow you innately know that
so you born knowing right and wrong
[__] then you got this book that'll
[__] your head up [__]
cause i sit there and read the
[__] over and over again and
some of the stories don't hold water
[__]
how the [__] you gonna tell me adam and
eve was the only two people
and then they had children what do you
do [__] his daughter how the [__] the
rest of us get hit
in incestual [__] you freak
then he told us noah built an ark
60 cubits by 80 cubits by 40 cubits
how the [__] you get every animal on
earth two by two in this motherboard
it's in africa how did deer from north
america get there did they swim
did they meet the [__] halfway
what crazy white man wrote this [__]
think about it
it's like nursery rhyme stories [__]
that jack and jill went up the hill
to fetch a pail of water what the [__]
is jack and jill going up a hill to get
water for water flows downhill
them little [__] up there
[__]
that's why they said jill broke broke
down and broke her crown [__] she lost
her virginity that [__] [__]
[Applause]
i don't believe jesus died on the cross
this is god's son he could walk on water
feed a thousand with a loaf of bread how
to [__] three nails
kill this [__] i know [__] with nine
bullet bones still walking around
his name is 50 cent you telling me this
[__] colder than jesus
think about it think it ain't illegal
yet think
[Applause]
don't just read [__] and just believe it
yeah that's the truth it's in the book
that the white man gave me and now i
don't have a country
[Applause]
you understand me you know man i think
the whole world is at war right now over
[__] religion
that's all this iraq [__] is about the
[__] christian
faith wants a foothold in muslim
territory
why because christianity is conducive to
wall street
islam is not conducive to wall street
you're not going to sell no nikes
because they wear their own [__]
you ain't gonna sell no maybelline cause
them [__] got bails on
it's not conducive to making money now
jesus
he conducive to making money jesus let
you [__] all week
suck some dick smoke some weed give him
twenty dollars on sunday he cool
[Applause]
mohammed wayne too strict got a face to
eat five times a day [__] be at the
club getting your groove on [__] that
time hit [__] with ease
[__] gotta travel with a confidence
[__] and be in the club
[Music]
[Applause]
[__] think you got a new dance
[__] what the [__]
so the war is really about religion
you understand me it's between jesus and
muhammad because [__] argue
over who the messenger is
the christians say jesus is the
messenger the muslims say muhammad is
the messenger
who gives a [__] who the messenger is
did you get the message
they got the same goddamn message did
you get the message
it's like killing the mailman cause it
wasn't the same mailman last week did
you get your check [__]
who gives a [__] who brought the
[__]
both of them brothers said do not praise
me praise he who sent
me but everybody called up oh jesus
jesus help me jesus jesus jesus
[__] ain't my job that's my pop's job
if i was jesus i wouldn't come back
i ain't [__] god be like uh jesus
time to go back no [__] no
hell no last time i was down there they
nailed a [__] up hell no
them one of us got guns now i ain't got
[__]
you can kiss my ass send moses that
[__] got a stick
send david at least that [__] got a
sling shot i'm your only son pop why you
keep doing this [__] to me man
[Applause]
i can hear some christian minds in here
eat going to hell
cause christians can't wait to send
somebody to hell you go in the hell
who the [__] told you don't mean like
god came down and said let that [__]
know he's going to hell i'm kind of busy
right now
i'm aiding god's image if i have a sense
of humor that means my
father has a sense of humor god probably
up there cracking up right now
he probably out there hey jesus come
here that crazy [__] made his own
he was talking about your [__] at your
whistle like this
you know you you die and then you go up
to get judged right
god pops in the dvd of your life well i
don't know about this right here
you mind explaining yourself
this might be the most arrogant thing i
say all night but i actually resent the
fact
that i'm gonna get judged someday like
if that's true
that somebody's gonna judge me that
doesn't even make any sense it's like
dude
you made me so this is your fuck-up all
right let's let's not try to
turn this around on me you know
jesus christ
[Applause]
you give me freedom of choice you make
[__] you have me suck at math
and you don't think this thing's gonna
go off the rails
like you set me up to fail and now you
got the balls
to now question your own goddamn work
dude if i made a car if i built a car
and it didn't run
i wouldn't like burn it forever you evil
pace of [__]
lighting on fire i wouldn't i would
troubleshoot
is there gas in the engine it's the
battery charge
anything beyond this i got to get a real
man to look at it but i believe in you
i'm gonna try and help you out